l'embarcation brille comme un sou neuf
et est fin prête à passer à l'action
après quelques tests en mer elle a été
conçue sur mesure pour les besoins des
sauveteurs de baleine par une entreprise
d'halifax les moteurs à faibles
émissions sont plus silencieux et ça
sera utile pour approcher des baleines
en détresse explique cet employé qui a
participé à la conception du bateau et
le pont est ouvert afin de pouvoir
manoeuvrer librement pour aider les
baleines piégé dans le cordage de pêche
le bateau est en route vers l'île de
campobello une île du nouveau brunswick
enclavé un territoire américain
il desservira principalement la baie de
fundy mais pourra aussi être
transportées par voie terrestre pour
intervenir dans le golfe du saint
laurent au besoin l'équipe de sauvetage
de l'organisme canadian wine institute
trépigne d'impatience et on est très
excité d'avoir un nouveau bateau parce
que j'en avais des anciennes zodiac plus
que 20 ans devient embarcations louis
qu'il utilisait depuis 2002 leur
nouvelle acquisition financée grâce à
une bourse accordée par pêches et océans
canada les rendra autonome et efficace
le bateau est plus rapide plus stable
plus sécuritaire aussi les opérations
auto une baleine c'est trop dangereux
vraiment un des bénévoles de l'équipe
joe hallett a d'ailleurs été tuée à
l'été 2010 est dans un accident lors du
sauvetage d'une baleine nous pensons
avec notre nouveau bateau que le
communication entre les membres des
tubes se vaut elle mieux depuis l'an
dernier une compensation financière est
accordée aux sauveteurs de baleine une
somme apprécié par les pêcheurs qui
constituent la majorité de l'équipe de
sauvetage de l'île de campobello s'ils
sont souvent blâmée pour les blessures
infligées aux baleines par les filets
les pêcheurs n'en demeure pas moins les
plus compétents pour leur porter secours
grâce à leur connaissance des cordages
et du comportement de ces animaux marins
et ce nouveau bateau arrive au bon
moment
les premières baleines
taux observés il ya quelques jours au
large de la nouvelle écosse il si fanny
bussières nicole radio canada à halifax